what what what really was cool about
about talking to him
is that
and and i and i've i you know i've had
four or five conversations with him now
what is so interesting about him is that
he really has not bought into
uh there are some questions he's not
gonna answer
but he hasn't bought into i'm gonna give
you a line of garbage speak
you know i mean yeah he's gonna pretty
much answer your question
you know hey it must have been cool for
you last year to accept the mvp award in
your hometown
and it was uh you know i wish i gave a
video uh acceptance i wanted to be
playing in the game and and like he he
wasn't happy and he wasn't gonna say oh
yeah really happy for my mom and my
coaches and all that stuff he wasn't
gonna say that because he wasn't happy
so i i do appreciate that about him
peter peter you've talked to him you
said four or five times now i it's
something that's jumped out to me and
even in your interview here just this
you know this past week you know when
you i he does seem
you know
more outgoing more confident as a person
in the interviews things like that does
that jump out to you or am i off base
there
well
i'll tell you chris last year twice
after games i think i talked to him
three times last year twice after games
and if you go over there and talk to him
and there's no notebook out
he's going to tell you everything that
just happened yeah it's that's he's that
kind of guy he
he knows he's the spokesman for the team
so he's going to be a bit careful but if
you go to him and just say hey let's
talk about that last drive tell me
everything that happened he's going to
tell you everything
that happened you know and and that's
that's one of the things i
i you know i appreciate about him peter
he's salty and rightfully so for not
getting to the super bowl last year they
were the best team in the nfl until the
titans knocked them off in the
divisional round they are now 0-2 in the
postseason with lamar jackson chris and
i were talking about this yesterday how
the pressure will mount as they continue
to go to the playoffs until they get
that first playoff win
uh and you talk both to lamar jackson
and john harbaugh did you sense any
regret whatsoever that they kind of took
their foot off the gas week 17 and
didn't have lamar jackson out there and
gave him what amounted to three weeks
off before that game against the titans
well you know it's the same thing that
tony dungy always used to say
about the curse of week 17. you know
mike mccarthy also said it uh before uh
uh aaron rodgers lost to the giants at
home you know and i think those teams
will always say i judge my team and and
i have to tell you mike i didn't ask
either guy about this
to be fair
but i do think
that in week 17 last year lamar jackson
was a kind of a beaten up guy
you know he wasn't injured per se and if
they needed the game he could have
played
but i do think that he needed
they felt like he needed that time now
well
will they do it differently this year i
certainly think they should do it
differently because i think taking 20
days off
in between games is a curse not a
blessing
so all right after talking to lamar
harbaugh you know you know these are
harbaugh's you know edgy guy i'm sure
chomping at the bit what was the big
takeaway about the attitude of the
ravens that you got from both of these
guys
you know in some ways chris it's you
know look it's easy to sit here and say
well you know honestly with the
exception of losing marshall yonda
they and and haydenhurst who was a good
contributing player with the except but
but yonder is the big loss they really
didn't have a bad loss and they added
probably the best
run
uh
you know rush
3-4 type end right in football at least
for the next couple of years in calais
campbell jk dobbins underrated guy i
think coming out of ohio state
uh you know and and the kid from uh
texas duvernay
uh who i think could step in and play
700 snaps
he is an nfl ready player from what the
ravens think
they're a better team
but you also say chris and this is
really significant look at all the
things you got to worry about
this is this is if you're worrying about
coven if you're worrying about how your
team is going to handle black lives
matter
if you worry about all of these things
in addition to football and then you
don't have pre-season games
who's going to handle that best
the team that handles that best has got
a huge advantage and i'll also say this
the team that doesn't have any covet
positives
you know
over the course of the season or who has
very few
that's the team that's going to have a
great chance to win this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports